looking for the perfect Father's Day
gift get him the most comfortable
t-shirts and boxers he'll ever wear
Leisure of NYC has Ultra Soft bamboo
boxers that feel light as air and their
premium supima cotton t-shirts are silky
smooth they become my go-to everyday
shirt get 15 off with the code Pacman
click the link below
we have to start today with yet another
defeat or failure for the so-called
anti-woke movement it's really important
to understand that all of these folks in
the current American right wing who
insists that America is embroiled in a
culture War around which apparently the
survival of the country depends which I
don't believe for a second one of the
things that they will rarely if ever
admit is that the war is extraordinarily
one-sided in the sense that it is the
retrograde right wing that has chosen to
fight these battles and it has been the
left having no choice but to react and
say hey the things you're asking for
don't make sense the battles you're
choosing to fight are battles that we
now have to get involved in not because
we want to but because you are trying to
discriminate and under the law create
multiple tiers of people and so on and
so forth but
they are suffering defeat after defeat I
told you earlier this week that the
Tennessee anti-drag bill has been
blocked it does appear to violate the
First Amendment we talked about a new
Gallup study that finds that support for
gay marriage is as high as ever in the
United States the Utah book ban has
backfired and actually led to the Bible
being banned and even the Book of Mormon
is now being looked at to say hey wait a
second if we're Banning sexual and
violent content don't these books also
have to be banned so it has been failure
after failure after failure and we now
have yet another defeat a federal judge
has blocked Florida's ban on gender
affirming care for minors in a narrow
ruling and has stated gender identity is
real the Associated Press reports saying
gender identity is real
a federal judge temporarily blocked
portions of a new Florida law that bans
trans miners from receiving puberty
blockers ruling Tuesday that the state
has no rational basis for denying
patients treatment they have many
irrational bases but no rational basis
this is a preliminary injunction from
Judge Robert Hinkle who says three trans
kids can continue receiving treatment
the lawsuit challenges the law that
Governor Ron DeSantis signed the same
week he announced a run for president
Hinkle said the elephant in the room
should be noted at the outset gender
identity is real the record makes this
clear despite the defense admissions
there are those who believe that
cisgender individuals properly adhere to
their natal sex and that trans
individuals have inappropriately chosen
a contrary gender identity male or
female just as one might choose whether
to read Shakespeare or Grisham uh this
is
extraordinarily important now I want to
we we've talked about so many different
aspects of this and of course this is
only a preliminary injunction or as Mike
pillow says of eliminary adjunction uh
regardless of how you say it this is
only a preliminary injunction and it's
possible that the law may be upheld I
want to talk about the religious
component here with many of these issues
because when we talk about the abortion
bans the attempts to ban gay marriage
the attempts to justify discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation or
gender identity often there are
religious justifications that are cited
now we could talk about how these
anti-woke positions aren't actually the
most popular positions we could there's
all sorts of things we could talk about
but because we've done that already
let me briefly address the religious
component to this we often see defenses
or justifications for these laws on
religious grounds and when I say
religious grounds I'm talking about
Christianity and when I say Christianity
I'm mostly talking about Evangelical
Christianity that those are that's the
strong religious movement in this
country that is pushing most of this
anti-woke stuff
I am wondering whether it would be
interesting to fight some of these laws
on the basis that they value that they
violate the religious beliefs of others
I'll give you an example according to
Jewish law
human life begins at Birth not at
conception it begins at the first breath
the majority of foundational Jewish
texts say a fetus does not attain
personhood until birth so Judaism does
not consider that life begins at
conception but rather at the moment of
the lit of delivery could I or any other
Jewish person Sue saying that
anti-abortion bills violate their
religious beliefs this has been
mentioned before and it would be an
extraordinarily interesting path to
approach uh to take to approach fighting
some of these laws now similarly we can
look at gender identity in many Jewish
belief systems
uh
it is recognized that there are six
distinct genders including male female
and intersex identities Reform Judaism
advocates for transgender Justice
affirms the value of all people
regardless of gender identity now of
course you could find Orthodox Judaism
which would have a different view but is
there not an argument to be made
that these anti-trans laws of all kinds
whether it comes to gender affirming
care or whether it comes to pronouns or
whether it comes to bathrooms or
whatever the case may be violates the
religious beliefs and practices of many
Jewish movements groups of Jews sects
maybe they would be called I think that
there is something here and I know it's
been mentioned in passing by some rabbis
if they are going to go the religious
Direction with this I would like to
explore fighting them on the same
grounds it's not going to be me
necessarily as a non-religious person I
consider myself you know culturally
ethnically and culinarily Jewish for
lack of a better term but this really
should be looked at and the if we want
to find a silver lining in this entire
cultural war that the right has
Unleashed upon the country it's that
they don't actually seem to have the
majority of the country on their side
and also that they don't see seem to
have the law on their side when it comes
to what they're pushing you're not going
to believe this because it sounds crazy
but it's true we don't know the reason
why we don't know if it was an accident
or if it was deliberate but the
Mar-A-Lago surveillance footage room
from which important surveillance
footage related to Donald Trump's
handling of classified documents that he
stole
has been flooded because a trump
employee at Mar-A-Lago drained the pool
into the surveillance room
it sounds unbelievable best Levin has a
piece in Vanity Fair about it called
we're sure there's a totally innocent
reason the Mar-A-Lago surveillance
footage room flooded amidst the doj's
Trump investigation here's a report from
CNN explaining what happened listen to
how insane this is and what I am
learning and have
and have earned
writers are Inc
and cause a flood at Mar-A-Lago back
October specifically one of the men a
maintenance worker who was captured on
some of this video surveillance tape
helping to move some of the boxes in and
out of that storage room he drained the
pool at Mar-A-Lago in October and when
that happened it flooded a room and that
room had I.T equipment in it that had
surveillance footage and so we don't
know
guys it's
uh can you believe this uh and it's not
clear if prosecutors believe that this
flood was intentional it
right but it is one of
them uh of things that just are
suspicious to prosecutors have raised
questions yeah and we do know too the
prosecutors have received some testimony
and some answers about what happened
there and some of the testimony is that
the video surveillance system wasn't
damaged in this flood but all of these
questions are going back to did Donald
Trump give some sort of direction or did
these people who were working for him
this maintenance worker and another man
who was captured on tape moving boxes
while not his body man were they taking
steps to inquire about the surveillance
footage or want to sort of all right you
you get it okay so at this point we
certainly can't say Trump ordered anyone
Hey listen how about this drain the pool
into the surveillance room and let's
damage all of the equipment so they
can't get the footage in fact there was
that one assertion made in this report
that that was not actually the cause of
the surveillance footage going missing
it went missing for whatever reason we
still don't know but apparently summer
claiming that it was not a result of the
pool being drained into the surveillance
room but it certainly doesn't sound good
there's a very good uh tweet thread from
Brian Allen who says an employee at
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago residence
drained the Resort's swimming pool last
October and ended up flooding a room
where computer servers containing
surveillance video logs were kept
sources familiar with the matter told
CNN while it is unclear if the room was
intentionally flooded or if it happened
by mistake the incident occurred amid a
series of events that Federal
prosecutors found suspicious that's the
understatement of the century at least
one witness has been asked by
prosecutors about the flooded server
room as part of the federal
investigation into Trump's handling of
classified documents according to one of
the sources the incident which has not
been previously reported came roughly
two months after the FBI retrieved
hundreds of classified documents from
Florida residents and as prosecutors
obtained surveillance footage to track
how White House records were moved
around the resort prosecutors have been
examining any effort to obstruct the
Justice Department's investigation after
Trump received a subpoena in May 22 for
classified documents so listen I I want
to be really upfront with everybody at
this point we cannot say that this was a
deliberate act or that it was ordered by
Donald Trump you know sometimes in
situations with multiple levels of
people involved they will keep the boss
isolated for plausible deniability and
so it could have been someone else who
said listen we're not even going to tell
Trump we're doing this but just drain
the pool into the surveillance room and
blah blah blah blah we we just it's all
speculation right now
but it just has guilt dripping all over
it and there are those who will say
David this is just too much of a
coincidence it's too much of a
coincidence that in the immediate period
where Donald Trump clearly lied about
what he did with the documents so then
investigators said all right well you've
got security cameras let's get a look at
the footage they slow walk providing the
footage and in the meantime the server
room floods although again in their
defense they're saying that's not the
reason why we can't get you the
surveillance footage it always stinks to
high heaven it's yet another one of
these incredible coincidences but we
can't say for sure that it was
deliberate and maybe it wasn't maybe it
was just incompetence I mean let's let's
be very honest
Trump ran on I will hire the best people
and then he hired terrible people
and when it blows up in his face he says
well they lied to me to get hired or
whatever the case may be we know bottom
line we know Trump doesn't hire the best
people and maybe that applies to the
same person who was both in charge of
the pool and moving the documents I
don't know I don't know why the same
person would be involved in both of
those things it's all extraordinarily
weird I want to hear from you
does this seem suspicious or is it
probably nothing let me know in a
YouTube comment in an email in a tweet
wherever and make sure of course that
you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel folks we're pushing to 2 million
subscribers and I would love for you to
be one of the two million I've mentioned
this before I will mention it again last
month we just got very strong numbers
for May on the YouTube channel this is
pretty interesting from a data
perspective in May almost 4 million
different people watched video clips on
YouTube almost 4 million like 3.8
million
but we have only 1.7 million YouTube
subscribers what this means is that
there are 2.1 million people out there
who watched Clips but didn't subscribe
remember you don't have to get notified
of every video just because you've
subscribed but it really helps us direct
the YouTube algorithm to direct people
to us when you do hit that subscribe
button so please do it let's go to 2
million let's take a very quick break
and then we're going to continue Chris
Christie folks I have good things to say
about Republican Chris Christie he had a
very strong Town Hall last night after
this short break
if you are still looking for the perfect
Father's Day gift check this out guys
know that it can be tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts but the search can
end now because our sponsor Leisure of
NYC sells the most comfortable t-shirts
and boxers that your dad is ever going
to wear all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
feels lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up it's also better for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
these incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's really the best out
there it just feels almost like Silk you
can let your dad walk around in a
scratchy t-shirt all day but come on you
can also treat him with the cloud soft
feel of supreme cotton so that it'll
actually love the shirt these are always
my go-to shirts and boxers no other
company even comes close to the Comfort
they provide and all of their products
are fair trade and made sustainably go
to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
it is so obvious that former Republican
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie is by
far the best Republican candidate
running for president this year he is at
least for now not doing the anti-woke
stuff he's willing to go after failed
twice impeached once indicted former
president Donald Trump he sounds like a
normal person although we obviously have
policy disagreements and the Maga people
don't want him we're going to look at
clips of Chris Christie's uh Town Hall
that he did yesterday announcing his
candidacy running against Trump and it's
after watching this town hall it's
clearer than ever to me if I were voting
in the Republican primary if I knew a
Republican would-be president it would
be Chris Christie that I would support
and this is not about glorifying or
glamorizing the guy
but he's willing to tell what should be
pretty uncontroversial truths he doesn't
equivocate when he's asked about Trump
and say well I'm not talking I'm here
focused on me not on Trump no he
understands you've got to go against
Trump and this was a very solid Town
Hall if more Republicans were like Chris
Christie we would have a much better
country than we do with people like
Trump and Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert and these sorts of
lunatics here's Chris Christie going
right after Trump he's not afraid
a lonely
self-consumed
self-serving
mirror hog
is not a leader well let me be clear
in case I have not been already
the person I am talking about
who is obsessed with the mirror
who never admits a mistake who never
admits a fault
and who always finds someone else and
something else to blame for whatever
goes wrong but finds every reason to
take credit for anything that goes right
is Donald Trump
and if we don't have that conversation
with you
we don't deserve
to ask for your vote I completely agree
Nikki Haley won't even say anything
other than well I'm a woman and I'm
younger and I'm a person of color and
Tim Scott says there's going to be a
contrast but I'm not making this about
other candidates now an audience member
during this town hall asked Chris
Christie if Trump's indicted and your
president will you pardon him when
DeSantis was asked about this he
basically said yes Chris Christie on the
other hand is saying almost certainly
not with a little bit of equivocation
but almost certainly not if Donald Trump
is indicted and you become president
will you pardon him
well I I have to tell you the truth
I can't completely answer that until I
know what he was charged with and
convicted of
okay so but but I'm not going to dodge
the answer okay
but I will tell you as a prosecutor
if I believe someone has gotten a full
and fair trial in front of a jury of
their peers
and especially someone in public life
who committed those crimes
when they held a public trust I can't
imagine pardoning them okay so I'm
hearing that is almost certainly not not
a perfect answer but a thousand times
better than the answer given by Ron
DeSantis Chris Christie did head on face
what he considers the biggest mistake of
his political career which was that some
of the people working for him had that
insane situation where they diverted
traffic off the George Washington Bridge
as political punishment I believe it was
to the mayor of Fort Lee New Jersey
although I don't now remember 100
obviously Chris Christie is going to
minimize the degree to which he was the
one at fault but he's taking
responsibility I just wish more
Republicans talked this directly because
they just you can't get a straight
answer out of almost any of these clowns
the biggest mistake I made in public
life was that I put a few people into a
position of authority at the Port
Authority of New York New Jersey who
went on a frocking detour to divert
traffic off the George Washington Bridge
without telling me without me knowing
anything about it they used my power and
my authority to play a fraternity prank
and it cost me a lot
it cost me credibility
it humiliated me publicly
and I should have never put those people
in that position
it's the biggest mistake I made there
you go the biggest mistake uh Chris
Christie also addressing the claim by
Donald Trump that if he were president
he would end the Russia Ukraine war in
24 hours Chris Christie pointing out the
way he would end it is by giving
everything to Russia and now I heard him
say if we made a president again
he would settle the Ukraine war in 24
hours did you hear that one that's a
beauty that's really in a career of
complete falsehoods
that makes the top five
but let's give him the benefit of the
doubt let's say Donald Trump could
settle it in 24 hours let me tell you
how he would he'd give Ukraine to Russia
and he said it
he said it on television he said it said
and he said look Russ is going to wind
up with Ukraine anyway so what's the
difference
that's how he settled in 24 hours he
calls Solinski and say hey guess what
time to raise the Russian flag up on the
pole we're out of here there are no
other Republican candidates willing to
say this they just aren't willing to do
it whether they believe it or not I
don't know but Chris Christie is at
least willing to say this stuff and it
is abundantly clear to me that there is
going to be one guy on the stage with
Trump if they get that far who is not
going to be pulling punches everybody
else is pulling punches Chris Christie
is not pulling punches here is Chris
Christie breaking out the Trump
impression on day one of his campaign it
was a mistake
in 2016 not to confront Donald Trump
early true because I knew that so much
of what he said was complete baloney
like I knew it I'm going to build the
greatest most wonderful wall across the
entire Mexico border and Mexico is going
to pay for it well like I knew as
someone who had governed that that was
complete bull
but I was like people aren't going to
believe that
they're not going to believe that
mistake
it was a mistake and uh he's completely
correct and he points out other bogus
claims that Trump has made he talks
about debt and deficit here and again
this isn't that Chris Christie
cheerleading segment it's there is
something notably different about Chris
Christie compared to all the other
candidates and how they are relating to
the issues notice that there isn't any
anti-woke stuff here at least he's
talking about
moderately real issues here he is about
national debt and pointing out Trump's
lies there as well the reason this is
going to be different this time sir is
because at least one of us
is gonna call him on the fact
that eight years ago he stood on the
stage of New Hampshire and said he was
going to balance the budget in four
years
and he left
with the biggest deficit of any
president in American history he said
he was going to eliminate the national
debt in eight years
Trump did say that he added three
trillion dollars
to the national debt in four years so a
very very strong Town Hall overall it'll
be interesting to see whether this moves
the needle at all in terms of polling
which right now is not great for Chris
Christie one last
clip from this Chris Christie made the
claim during the town hall that if Biden
had been running against someone
different in 2020 Biden would have lost
that Biden was a poor candidate but one
because so many people so acutely
dislike Donald Trump and it's certainly
possible that that is true it's possible
out there let me be very clear I am
going out there to take out Donald Trump
but here's why I want to win
and I don't want him to win
and guess what if you put DeSantis and
Haley and Pence
and Tim Scott
that's it I'll stop there
on true serum they tell you the same
thing here's the difference here's the
difference you have to put me on true
serum to tell you
okay so that's why there are not
multiple Lanes to the Republican
nomination
that is a political science professor's
dream
there is one lane yep it's the
Republican nomination and he's in front
of it and if you want to win you better
go right through him
because let me guarantee you something
from knowing him for 22 years everybody
he gonna kind of go through me
and he's going to try to go through Ron
and Nikki and Tim and anybody else who
stands in his way all right so Chris
Christie gets it Chris Christie
understands what's going on Trump's not
a good candidate but Trump is leading
the Republican nomination the path to
the nomination is through Trump it's not
taking your two percent like Nikki Haley
or sorry four percent like Nikki Haley
or two percent like Tim Scott and just
talking about how you're going to be
positive and whatever uh the path is
through Trump and the question is
whether Chris Christie will be able to
do it I don't know I'm curious to see
what polling looks like in two weeks in
the meantime all sorts of people
reacting to Chris Christie's candidacy
just by talking about his weight Donald
Trump was so triggered by Chris
Christie's Town Hall during which Chris
Christie attacked Trump on issues on
facts on deficit on Ukraine right like
not doing the anti-woke stuff Trump was
so triggered
that he went after Chris Christie
because Chris Christie is obese but
Trump is obese and this is quite a
double standard that I want to talk
about Donald Trump posting to his
platform truth social essential quote
how many times did Chris Christie use
the word small does he have a
psychological problem with size actually
his speech was small and not very good
it rambled all over the place and nobody
had a clue of what he was talking about
hard to watch boring but that's what you
get from a failed Governor New Jersey
who left office with a seven percent
approval rating and then got run out of
New Hampshire this time it won't be any
different Trump then posting a
photoshopped picture of Chris Christie
from yesterday's Town Hall
photoshopped to put Chris Christie at a
buffet with all sorts of different foods
in front of him look I can't even
identify what these foods are
um looks like maybe some kind of
Italian-American food or something like
that hard to hard to actually see
um so Trump just basically using fat
jokes against Chris Christie
I continue to not understand
how it is
that Trump isn't being called out for
the fact that he makes fun of other
people's weight but Trump is obese Trump
is obese yes he has figured out ways to
disguise it and yes Chris Christie is
more obese than Donald Trump but
remember there's this whole story where
Trump claims to be six foot three and
239 pounds which quite literally puts
him one pound away from technically
being obese according to BMI BMI is not
a perfect measure by any means but it
gives us some some idea but we know that
that's not true we know that Trump isn't
as tall as he says and it's very obvious
that Trump is much heavier than he
claims to be and if you even adjust his
height by an inch or his weight by a
pound he becomes obese if you look at
pictures of trump next to Obama they
look to be roughly the same height we
know Obama's only six one not six three
at 239 that makes Trump obese we know
that there are pictures of trump with
former baseball player Alex Rodriguez we
know A-Rod is 6'3 and he looks way
taller than Trump and so if we assume
Trump is actually 6-1 instead of six
three unless Trump is 200 pounds or
under he's obese and you look at Trump
and it's very obvious that he's not 40
pounds lighter than he claims to be he's
somewhere between 10 and 30 pounds
heavier than he claims to be so I say
all of this
to remind you
that Trump is obese but he makes fun of
Chris Christie's weight and part of this
comes from the magical thinking that is
not based in reality that his followers
fall for yeah Trump is right Chris
Christie's fat so he would be a bad
president but the guy you support is
also fat yeah but that's different
that's totally different or he's not
actually fat he's not obese or they're
lying about this or they're lying about
that how does an obese guy get away with
making fun of everybody else's weight I
don't understand it and I'm going to
have one more clip about this because
there's actually another element to this
story Fox news reporter John Roberts
also made a fat joke about Chris
Christie and then he ended up
apologizing about the joke why don't
they ever joke about Trump's weight on
Fox Trump is obese here is the joke I
guess it's a joke I don't know from John
Roberts to to use a a modification of a
metaphor that we were using in the panel
earlier today it's like you have two
milkshakes right the Republican party
used two milkshakes and and this one
representing almost half the party
because that's what the polling shows
has got one straw in it and that's
Donald Trump's straw right and the other
milkshake which represents the
non-donald Trump part of the Republican
party has how many straws in it now and
now we're gonna have Chris Christie's
drawing there and judging by Chris
Christie's physical stature he could
drink a lot of that milkshake if he
wanted to oh boy so okay so standard
Chris Christie fat joke and then John
Roberts uh later apologizing and saying
as soon as it came out of his mouth he
knew it was a mistake uh hey before we
go on I I just want to take a moment to
address something because I really do
feel terrible about it this is now a
very serious and somber John Roberts
earlier on the show I was making an
analogy to describe the Republican voter
pool right and I made a comment that I
meant to be light-hearted but
immediately realized was hurtful toward
Governor Chris Christie I should not
have said what I said I deeply regret it
and I sincerely apologize to the
governor there you go a very sincere and
you can tell he means it because he used
his sincere Anchorman voice as opposed
to the normal voice that he uses so
listen the fat jokes are in poor taste
but I just want someone to explain the
hypocrisy why does Trump get a pass on
his obesity uh Trump has been obese for
as long as he's been in political life
Fox News never brings it up Chris
Christie announces yesterday and there
are already fat jokes on Fox News and
there's sort of this irony
where John Roberts apologizes for making
a fat joke about Chris Christie when
this has actually been something they've
been doing on the network for a while
and Trump has been doing to Chris
Christie for a while as well uh I I
don't know I'm curious to hear from
folks in the audience what is the
explanation for this is it that his
loyal loyal followers truly are the cult
members we believe them to be and so it
doesn't matter they're sort of blinded
by their cult following of trump is it
because they don't actually even care
about obesity it's just what can we use
as a weapon against our opponents if our
opponent's overweight we'll use that but
if the guy we like is overweight we
don't actually care this is the
hypocrisy of the right wing this is the
nasty scapegoating nature of the right
wing they can dish it out they often
can't take it and of course of course of
course of course they are hypocrites
period end of story all of these stories
will be on our Instagram which you can
find by searching in Instagram for David
packman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
so let's spend just a few minutes on
Donald Trump and then we're going to
move on to Bobby Kennedy Jr and other
candidates as you can see this 2024 race
is really filling out where we're
talking about Chris Christie and Ron
DeSantis and Bobby Kennedy Biden and
Trump is interestingly a relatively
smaller and smaller piece of that I do
want to play this clip for you Donald
Trump I I mean I feel so stupid even
saying this Donald Trump laid out some
policy ideas yesterday in videos of
course he didn't really lay out policy
ideas he basically ranted claimed he
will do things he almost certainly won't
do and continued to tell the exact same
lies that he's been telling for years
we're going to look at Donald Trump now
announcing
a new health care plan and I know that
many of you will say well but David
Trump announced that his new health care
plan was coming out two weeks later than
August of 2020. don't you remember when
Trump said I do remember that I do
remember that we'll look at that clip in
a moment here is Trump now as if he
hasn't ever commented on this for the
last six years and we don't remember or
how many years now eight years as if we
don't remember uh the fact that he's
made these promises many times Trump
says he's gonna come up with a new
health care plan and I know I I know
guys I know when I'm back in the white
house I will establish a special
presidential commission really of
independent Minds who are not bought and
paid for by big Pharma and I will charge
them with investigating what is causing
the decades-long increase in chronic
illnesses I understand big Pharma I
believe better than anybody else right I
know where they're coming from
and then I will ask them to publish
recommendations for how every American
child can have a safe and healthy
childhood there you go so it's going to
be another new idea of what we need to
do on health care now you might remember
that when Trump was running in 2015 and
2016 he famously said he was going to
have a beautiful health care plan to
replace Obamacare the only thing that
Republicans proposed in 2017 would have
led to 24 to 32 million people losing
health care so that didn't go anywhere
and then there was this classic famous
moment during the Chris Wallace
interview in 2020 where Trump said it
was only two weeks away from a new
health care plan for three and a half
years
uh
she heard me yesterday was signing a
health care plan within two weeks right
a full and complete health care plan
that the Supreme Court decision on DACA
gave me the right to do yeah so we're
going to solve we're going to sign an
immigration plan a health care plan and
various other plans
we will be doing various plans within
the next two weeks none of it ever
happened and Trump is telling the same
lie again and this really starts to get
to Insanity how many times can you fall
for the same lie what was that thing
George W bush said uh shame on you fool
me once shame on you
fool me twice You Can't Get Fooled Again
something along those lines was what
George W bush said and um honestly folks
this is just nonsense nonsense stuff at
this point if you believe okay now Trump
really is going to get the health care
plan done if you really believe that at
this point it's sort of like I've got a
Brooklyn bridge to sell you uh for a
dollar that that's the level on which
we're operating speaking of Trump's
followers Trump has rebranded his
followers
magadonians in an all caps erratic truth
social post trust Central yeah Trump
posting quote we are magedonians we are
very smart we stick together as one we
follow truth socially
we put America First and we will make
America great again
posting this apropos of nothing just out
there randomly turning on caps lock and
posting this nonsense Trump giving
advice to Fox News as well quote this is
in all caps Fox should embrace Maga
their Prime Time viewership is down 37
percent from just a year ago all because
the very smart even brilliant
magadonians know that despite all the
fake lip service Fox News is pushing Ron
Des Sanctus or anyone else for that
matter because they hate the greatest
America first president to ever put on a
suit and tie me they are all globalists
and globalists will never make America
great again so going conspiratorial
completely unhinged completely off the
rails and these are the sorts of claims
that I guess his followers are still
desperate for all of that has been in
capital letters continuing in capital
letters attacking Alvin Bragg prosecutor
in New York saying quote wow legal
experts are saying that D.A Alvin Bragg
will be immediately forced to drop his
weak and disparaged case against quote
Trump because his top investigator
Jeremy Rosenberg corruptly colluded with
the disgrace disbarred and convicted
felon and perjurer in attempting to
frame me with a crime that doesn't even
exist they apparently became close
friends with lifestyle money spent a
crime this on top of Clinton lawyer
turned prosecutor Mark pomerance
illegally writing a book on the case
this is a former president of the United
States this is a man who says elect me
again give me give me another four years
and I will solve all of your problems
the very problems I didn't solve when I
was president the first time and he
wants to do it while claiming everybody
has turned against him he's the biggest
victim in the world and that he actually
won the 2020 election at a certain point
folks you know I said it earlier Chris
Christie is so obviously the best
Republican candidate running right now
but the Maga people don't want him if
the Maga people in 2023
look at who's running and they say oh I
want Trump trump is what makes sense I
believe Trump I believe Trump will do
the things he's saying if that's what
they believe they deserve to get Trump
as their nominee and to lose badly
really badly the problem is we can't
just look away and assume that Trump
will lose because it's not at all
obvious that Trump will lose and that's
maybe the scariest part of all of this
after the break we will talk about
what's going on on the Democratic
primary side you might be saying what
Democratic primary we will talk about
that after the break
you value what we do at the David Pacman
show remember to support us on patreon
go to patreon.com davidpackman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos The Daily bonus show the
commercial free Daily Show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it hasn't
been my goal to talk very much about
Bobby Kennedy Junior's candidacy for the
Democratic presidential nomination we
did talk about his campaign launch we
talked about polling we talked about the
undeniable reality that the DNC is
simply not going to hold debates as they
never do when they have an incumbent
president running for re-election but
Bobby Kennedy Jr has really been scaling
up the nuttiness he did a Twitter spaces
with Twitter owner Elon Musk and while
there were fewer technical glitches
there were there was certainly no
shortage of lies and the things that
Bobby Kennedy Jr is saying don't make
any sense they don't make any sense and
it's it's it's almost getting concerning
to a degree as I told you before I had
dinner once with Bobby Kennedy with a
small group Charming smart able to talk
logically about so many different issues
it's just anything so many different
things knowing that he had some odd
views about vaccines at the time
but now it's just building building he's
become the darling of Newsmax and other
right Wingers and we have to look at
some of the claims he's making because
they are so wrong and so dangerous
Business Insider summarizing the recent
Twitter spaces with Elon Musk says
Robert F Kennedy Jr Compares Elon Musk
to the patriots who died fighting in the
American Revolution what on Earth and
blames antidepressants for mass
shootings Elon Musk hosted RFK Jr in a
bizarre Twitter space bizarre is right
in a bizarre Twitter spaces conversation
littered with falsehoods and conspiracy
theories Kennedy compared musk to
Patriots who died in the Revolutionary
War he also claimed prior to the
introduction of Prozac there were no
mass shootings in the United States news
to historians
um let's go through this in pieces
Kennedy said thank you for your service
to our country Elon we lost between 25
000 and 70 000 people during the
revolution who died to give us our
Constitution and those people also put
their livelihoods on the line they put
their property on the line they put
their financial status and their social
status on the line for principles I've
watched you do the same thing
folks
he can't he's too smart to believe that
right he's just paying obviously bogus
lip service to Elon Musk I hope right I
hope uh Elon Musk Elon Musk is a
billionaire who owns a bunch of
companies
has a net worth around or over 200
billion although maybe it's less now
because of the decline in Tesla stock I
don't know
the patriots who fought in the American
Revolution as Bobby Kennedy says we're
mostly Farmers Artisans merchants and
laborers who quite literally risked
their lives and livelihoods for the
cause of Liberty and Independence uh
from England Elon Musk hasn't sacrificed
his life nor his fortune yes he's lost a
few billion what's a few billion to a
guy who's as rich as he is he's
benefited from government subsidies
government contracts tax breaks for his
businesses the patriots who fought in
the American Revolution pledged their
lives fortunes and quite frankly uh uh
uh put so much more at risk than Elon
Musk has even thought of risking Elon
Musk has an even consistently shown
support for democracy or human rights in
some situations he has done some
praising of authoritarian regime games
he's criticized some democratically
elected leaders he spread misinformation
about covet I mean listen I am not one
of these people who says Elon Musk is a
uniquely bad guy check out my appearance
on the Lex Friedman podcast where I say
I think the focus on Elon Musk is just
overblown what he has done to advance
electric vehicle technology and Battery
Technology it's fantastic it really is
SpaceX super interesting he's done a lot
of great things but he's also done
things that I think are terrible and
we're now saying he's like the American
Patriots who fought for independence in
the American Revolution it's just a
crazy thing for Bobby Kennedy to say
um he also talked about uh the SSRI
violence connection
and he said that
um as the article here points out he
laid the blame for the ink massive
increase in mass shootings not on guns
but on pharmaceutical companies for
marketing antidepressants quote prior to
the introduction of Prozac we had almost
none of these events in our country now
of course that's not true Prozac was
introduced in the United States in 1987
approved by the FDA there were endless
mass shootings before that certainly
fewer the population was smaller and
I'll tell you what the real reasons were
but if you look on Wikipedia at a list
of mass shootings you see a bunch of
mass shootings in the 20s when the
American population was much smaller
um not so many in the 30s and 40s and
50s but then they start to increase in
the 1960s we saw mass shootings in the
1970s we saw way more mass shootings in
the 19 80s before the introduction of
Prozac we saw even more so what you
actually see
is that the number of mass shootings
scaled with not only the American
population but the widespread
availability of firearms as well as
lacks gun laws when you look at a
general limit now okay let's then so
we've seen that it's not true that there
were almost no mass shootings before
Prozac just not true
what about a general link between ssris
Prozac being one type of SSRI medication
and violence more generally and this has
been asserted before the claim that
ssris cause violence it's sort of like
blaming the fire extinguisher for the
fire there's a fire in these all there's
all these fire extinguishers there all
of a sudden ssris are prescribed for a
number of different reasons including
depression anxiety or personality
disorders most people with depression
anxiety and personality disorders aren't
prone to violence but some are and if
you believe as some do that compared to
the general population particularly
certain personality disorders might
predispose someone to violence you might
be able to might might you might be able
to find a correlation between those
taking SS our eyes and violence but that
would not be proof that the violence is
caused by the ssris it would be the
classic confounding Factor this is like
basic you know first level College
research methods and stats sort of stuff
in other words it would be
the underlying mental disorder rather
than the medication that might be the
cause of the violence but it's really
important also to mention that most
people who are quote mentally ill are
not violent it's also really important
to mention that if you also look at the
studies that look at ssris and violence
they're often significant methodological
limitations small sample size lack of
control groups failure to account for
other factors that might influence
violence like substance use or abuse
history of aggression psychosocial
stressors economic issues ETC so right
now the causal link between ssris and
violence is extraordinarily weak now
I'll give you another side to this
discussion there are studies that
suggest
ssris properly administered can reduce
Violence by improving mood and impulse
control for the those who are taking
them so not only is it unfair and
misleading to blame the ssris for
violence based on what we currently know
it actually could be the opposite
um this is getting to be pretty
dangerous stuff and I don't really know
what the end game is here for Bobby
Kennedy Jr as you all know he's not
going to be the nominee there aren't
going to be debates I would love to see
debates and I think everyone who wants
to run should run but when you see the
right Wingers increasingly excited and
titillated by Bobby Kennedy's campaign
that really tells you a lot about the
sort of campaign that is being run here
and it's not a particularly exciting
campaign to me I know that there's a
handful of people in the audience who
seem to like it but I think that it is
essentially a ruse sort of like Tulsi
gabbard was a ruse
if I'm wrong I will correct the
statement in the future I almost wasn't
going to talk about this but Tucker
Carlson's new Twitter show is really
really really bad and it is an
interesting media story to follow so
we're going to look at a couple minutes
of this Tucker released episode 1
episode 1 of Tucker on Twitter it is ten
and a half minutes long it has been
viewed over 70 million times since
posted yesterday at 6 pm
um what I came away with is that when
you strip away the multi-million dollar
production of Fox News the expensive set
someone controlling the teleprompter for
Tucker now he controls it himself with a
sort of a mouse wheel of sorts a team of
producers and the graphics when you
strip it all away to its bare core for
lack of a better term
it turns out that Tucker is actually
pretty lame like Lamer than the average
YouTuber I have to say
let's take a look at episode one tell me
if you find this compelling
another new crane the rushing wall of
water wiped out entire Villages
destroyed a critical hydropower plant
and as of tonight puts the largest
nuclear reactor in Europe in danger of
melting down so if this was intentional
it was not a military tactic it was an
act of terrorism the question is who did
it well let's see the kokovka dam was
effectively Russian it was built by the
Russian government it currently sits in
russian-controlled territory the dams
Reservoir supplies it's sort of like at
this point we're 37 seconds in it's
already obvious like okay if I watch
another couple minutes
he'll probably just blame Ukraine you
know it's like it's do you do we even
really need to watch this then we'll
skip ahead this is sort of like closer
to the middle just to give you a little
more of a sense of this Russians are
dying it's the best money we've ever
spent Graham says a smile spreads across
his thin quivering lips as he forms the
words he looks like a starving man
contemplating a breath sounds like he's
reading fan fiction now breakfast buffet
the aroma of death has aroused Lindsey
Graham thanks so much replies zolensky
he feels the same way right see there's
nothing dark here just two middle-aged
guys celebrating the killing of a
population they don't seem like the kind
of people who'd enjoy flooding Villages
or starting a famine in any case who
cares if they are it's really not your
business your job is to support Ukraine
watch Nikki Haley a republican candidate
for president explain this principle on
CNN a win for you so then he plays a
clip of Nikki Haley and then we'll look
at uh sort of the end and how he wraps
this whole thing
or will we now it's glitching badly let
me see if we can get back to the the
wrap up here here we go U.S government
has managed to classify more than a
billion so-called public documents so at
this point we can't possibly know what
our leaders are doing we're not allowed
to know
by definition that is not a democracy
yet it's fine with the media secrecy is
a powerful tool of control
stop asking how we got so rich here's
another story about racism go eat each
other
that's the program that's how most of us
now live here in the United States
manipulated by lies silenced by taboos
it is unhealthy and it's dehumanizing
and we're tired of it as of today we've
come to Twitter which we hope will be
the shortwave radio under the blankets
right we're told there are no
Gatekeepers here if that turns out to be
false we'll leave but in the meantime we
are grateful to be here we'll be back
with much more very soon
there you go folks and there is a little
outro with Tucker I guess fishing or
something like that yeah you know it's
it is very interesting when you see him
stripped of the accoutrements of
corporate media it's extraordinarily
mediocre the pace if you want to watch
the full 11 minutes I encourage you to
do it the pacing is very so so there's
too much time spent belaboring certain
points it just isn't very good and
that's what's really interesting when we
look you know the real media there's a
couple media stories here
what happens to Tucker's platform once
he's just posting videos to twitter
um one of the things you know I I am not
saying this to Pat myself on the back
but one of the things that is notable
about people who slowly build online
platforms like we've done on YouTube
Twitter Facebook podcast Etc is you
don't get a big audience you can bring
with you like Tucker got 70 million
views on this video because of things he
has done previously with multi-million
dollar production and that's great
that's a fantastic thing and who would
turn that down right that's a that's a
beautiful thing but one of the things
that's unclear is would he be able to
build it in the same way if he hadn't
been handed those things from these
major corporate media outlets and we
don't know the answer we'll never know
because he was able to bring this large
audience with him but to all the small
YouTubers and podcasters where we go you
know we I think back to the start of the
show we got a hundred downloads on a
podcast and then now we're approaching a
million downloads a month and 70 5
million views a month on video across
all of our different platforms when we
those numbers were built slowly over
time and there's a real question as to
what is this stripped down Tucker going
to be able to retain from that original
audience I'm as curious as anybody else
I'm also curious as far as a media story
is this a viable business of some kind
um and if so how is it going to be
monetized we will see we will see we
have a voicemail number that number is
219 to David P here's a call of very
concise and pithy question
hey David uh the declared Republican
candidate who is the most reasonable
candidate in your opinion thanks for all
you do man it's Chris Christie as we
talked about earlier it's so obvious who
is the most reasonable Republican
candidate it is Chris Christie a
relatively moderate former Governor from
New Jersey who understands the reality
that to get the Republican nomination
you have to go through Trump
yes he is a self-aggrandizing sort of
guy but he's at least willing to admit
some mistakes as he did during
yesterday's Town Hall event
he understands even if I disagree with
him on the solutions he understands
issues in a far deeper way than many of
these other people that are running and
uh that is probably why he's polling one
percent at least right now he just
announced we don't have any announce any
polling from after Christie's
announcement it'll be interesting to see
in 10 to 14 days whether the polling
moves at all he's pulling one percent
right now
if you came to me and you said David the
next president will be one of these
Republicans it won't be Joe Biden it'll
be one of these Republicans who do you
want to see as president it is obviously
and undoubtedly Chris Christie from the
current slate of Republicans if you
disagree with me please let me know we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today lying Congressman George Anthony
devolder Santos has lost his attempt to
Shield the people who gave him his bail
money
um he is no longer going to be able to
keep them secret that is fascinating who
might they be we will discuss Oklahoma
has okayed its first religious charter
school and this immediately is setting
up a war over separation of church and
state because taxpayer money is used for
that charter school and a Texas sheriff
is recommending criminal charges over
the Ron DeSantis migrant flight stunt
who would be charged and when and for
what crimes we will tell you on the
bonus show sign up at Joe joinpakman.com
it is the world famous and award-winning
bonus show admittedly they are all
Awards we give out but they are still
great I'll see you then or back on the
program tomorrow
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors looking for the
perfect Father's Day gift get him the
most comfortable t-shirts and boxers
he'll ever wear Leisure of NYC has Ultra
Soft bamboo boxers that feel light as
air and their premium supima cotton
t-shirts are silky smooth they become my
go-to everyday shirt get 15 off with the
code Pacman click the link below